I don't think science is a slog like I
think of it like athletics no you're
practicing right you know you you don't
get to be a world-class tennis player by
just walking onto the court and you got
to hit a lot of balls over the net Hey
and so to me the whole process of that
like like even though I was doing sort
of the same experiment for a long time
my brain wasn't my brain was thinking
about things and how could this be in
solving problems and and you know taking
in information and wandering right and
so I think that part of it is that to do
something really new and really
remarkable it's not gonna be easy that's
true in any vocation that's challenging
so you don't just do it on day one the
second thing is that you're getting
better and better even when you're doing
experiments that are failing
sometimes just cuz you screw them up
with your hands and sometimes because
the strategy isn't right to me all of
that is part of the honing your end of
the making you a more refined and better
and more successful scientist the third
thing is that I enjoyed it you know like
I'm in this battle with this bacterium
and this bacterium is winning you know
that's insulting right and so I enjoyed
like I will figure this out like a
challenge like a game you know like when
I was a kid
like a game that I wanted to win and
then the the you know and so that that's
all part of it it's ego and and fun and
then and then I would also say like I
always thought of it sort of to like
when you go on a hike like I'm a hiker
you know you do get to the top and
there's a big Vista but and it's worth
the nine hours to get there but the nine
hours were good too right to get to the
top of the mountain right like that's
all part of it and I I don't know I like
all of those parts of it and then I
guess the other thing I would say about
when people say it's hard like I say
it's challenging and I don't want a job
that is easy and then bores me and that
I go home at five o'clock and watch
reality TV wait
I want to spend my life two things one I
want to make a contribution and I want
to help people and I want to change the
way people think at least about bacteria
but like I want to be challenged every
single day I don't ever want to watch
the clock go around wondering when I get
to go home like for me often I'll be
thinking about whatever and I'll look
I'll think I'm hungry and I'll look up
this eight o'clock at night and the time
will have flown by because what my brain
gets to do every day is fun and it's
unstoppable and I think about it that
night I think about it in the shower I
wake up in the middle of the night right
and I just admit to myself that I like
that and I don't think it's wrong to say
I like that right and that's a really
remarkable way to get to live your life
right I like you get to live your life
always learning right always being
around curious people always changing
the way the world thinks about something
and there's a relentlessness to it which
is really really good like no matter
what I'm doing if I'm doing the dishes
or I'm ironing I'm thinking about quorum
sensing right and that's like there's no
better feeling than that
you